the panic attack scene in Puss and Boots
The Last Wish received praise for its
accuracy and went viral on Twitter
getting compared favorably to other
worse animated panic attacks like those
in Velma and even Paw Patrol the movie
but when comparing those scenes the
discussions often Overlook the
fundamental challenge of showing a panic
attack on screen it's not just the risk
of inaccuracy or resorting to
insensitive cliches but also the fact
that panic attacks happen internally
it's entirely possible for a panic
attack to happen to somebody and nobody
else even knows when I was 23 I had my
first panic attack on stage my parents
were there and couldn't tell it was
happening so this phenomenon presents a
challenge for audio-visual mediums like
movies and TV you can only perceive a
character's intense emotions as an
outside Observer so how do you show
anxiety
the panic attack scene in Puss in Boots
shows the importance of accuracy and
sensitivity when portraying severe
anxiety on screen showing common
symptoms like the loss of motor control
and elevated heart rate and the
importance of breathing exercises to try
to calm down and at the same time it
uses many filmmaking techniques to
present those internal feelings to the
external viewer because animation is an
abstraction of the physical world the
medium can capture the feeling of
anxiety through metaphors that extend
past conventional human physicality a
movie like inside out represents fear as
a thin wiry humanoid according to
director P doctor the design is based on
a raw nerve making anxiety observable by
representing it as a skittish and
brittle looking character in Puss in
Boots Puss also has exaggerated features
so when his episode starts it's easy to
see his hair stand up and pupils change
we also feel his subjective perception
of time by slowing down the rest of the
scene while his heart rate and reactions
speed up but despite being animated Puss
in Boots actually borrows a lot of live
action techniques to depict anxiety we
first enter his Panic episode using a
conventional Dolly Zoom which Alters the
space around him and when puss sees
death coming for him the color palette
changes from Mostly orange to mostly
green as he runs away the extreme
wide-angle close-ups also physically
distort his face and the Frantic blurry
camera on him contrasts the calmer
cleaner framing we get outside of his
perspective combined together these
physical alterations of the frame
externalize puss's internal emotions
when we're in his perspective we
visualize the same Distortion of space
and time that he does through
exaggeration we get a depiction that's
more honest the use of these techniques
to show anxiety is nothing new Twitter
pointed out that Paw Patrol the movie
uses similar effects like the Distortion
of time Dolly zoom and the sound of a
quickening heartbeat but what makes Puss
in Boots so much better is the moment
after this exaggerated sequence where
the movie snaps into realism as puss
lies against a tree and the camera holds
while his heart races and he tries to
calm down because this realistic moment
happened after the conventional animated
intensity it hits that much harder the
movie earns a simpler more realistic
portrayal of in this moment because we
already know what's going on in puss's
head
compare the techniques you put some
boots to was seen in the TV show Velma
which not only has an inaccurate and
insensitive portrayal of panic attacks
but it also uses cinematic techniques in
the wrong way the scene starts off with
some classic anxiety representing
choices like having the camera at a tilt
and distorting velma's features the
scene also abstracts anxiety by turning
her mom into a monster-like figure and
showing her heart race using the cliche
of a heart literally beating outside of
her chest but despite ticking the boxes
the scene loses all emotional resonance
because of how quickly Velma exits all
these exaggerations and snaps into the
real world it's the complete opposite of
Puss in Boots without lingering on the
moment the techniques don't show what
anxiety feels like they're just a setup
for a punch line which both makes light
of anxiety and undermines the Very
techniques that can show what anxiety
feels like Velma shows that animation
doesn't always have the upper hand when
portraying anxiety in fact there are
plenty of live action depictions that do
it better in live action filmmakers
can't represent anxiety as abstractly as
an animation which often leads to more
grounded performance-centric represent
but live-action filmmakers can still get
creative as Bo Burnham explains what his
anxiety feels like in inside the shot
jumps from a dark static wide shot to a
zoom in close-up with bright moving
lights in the background this extreme
contrast shows how anxiety can come out
of nowhere and like the shot itself
often leads to sensory overload
similarly in his film 8th grade Burnham
shows Kayla's anxiety by pulling the
camera in and out of focus dropping
frames and having Kayla in the camera
out of sync Burnham's techniques show
how Eden live action can break
conventional film techniques to show
anxiety opting for emotional resonance
over continuity and Puss in Boots
actually also has intentional continuity
errors one moment cuts from Puss turning
around to a shot of him facing death
directly it's a subtle small choice but
the instant position change makes puss
feel slightly more out of sync with the
world around him so sometimes subtle
choices can work just as well in the
last of us TV series Joel has a panic
attack and to show his unease the camera
makes the unusual choice of having the
sun move in and out of the frame and
eventually and behind Joel creating a
sort of silhouette in typical filmmaking
this lighting would have been a
distracting mistake but in the context
of a panic attack this in-camera light
Distortion reflects the Distortion going
on in Joel's mind and wouldn't you know
it Paw Patrol the movie does the same
thing with the same techniques reused
over and over It's tricky to know when
an anxiety sequence feels authentic or
veers into the cliche which explains why
so many anxiety scenes become memes
online I tend to personally appreciate
the more subtle presentations in the
movie The Aviator I'm less moved by
Leonardo DiCaprio's breakdown in his car
and more moved in the moment prior when
his character feels the anxiety coming
and has trouble dealing with it shyness
isn't cowering in a corner and not
wanting to speak shyness is wanting to
speak at every moment and not being able
to that's what anxiety is but at the
same time I am very excited to see the
spider within a spider-verse story an
upcoming Spider-Man short film that
depicts Miles Morales battling with
mental health issues if it's anything
like the first two animated spider-verse
films the short will definitely use
fresh and Innovative techniques to
depict anxiety that will transcend the
repetition and cliche that many anxiety
scenes fall into
when Puss in Boots came out countless
articles and Twitter threads popped up
discussing its authenticity and it does
do a great job representing anxiety by
using both animated and live action
techniques to capture the feeling of a
panic attack and its sequences like
these that show the interesting
challenge anxiety provides to a
filmmaker because it's an abstract but
deeply intense feeling it's an
opportunity for filmmakers to stretch
camera movements Lighting and Sound
design to their limits yet filmmakers do
often get anxiety wrong and that
challenge reflects the real life
challenge of anxiety unlike physical
illness mental illness is hard to show
because many of the symptoms are
internal yet filmmakers are up to the
challenge and the best ones know how to
use either exaggeration or subtlety to
capture the nuance and genuine cruelty
that severe anxiety inflicts on millions
of people anxiety is hard to talk about
and it's even harder to actually go
through especially when you have to go
through it alone but thanks to talented
artists you're not alone now you see it
and
[Music]